might still trickle in a little bit but
we should probably get
get underway uh we're delighted to have
luca come back for part two of average
case complexity uh luca over to you
kim so
let's see how much progress we
made since yesterday so we talked about
what is a distribution problem
uh we talked about various definitions
of
efficiency for algorithms and perhaps we
will
kind of continue to highlight
some
various options for exactly what we mean
by not going to be efficient
and then we talked about how to
get reductions between problems that
preserve average case tractability
and
we got an example of
np completeness with respect to this
kind of
reduction that used data compression in
a fundamental way
now the main
topic but then it will sort of be an
opportunity to talk about lots of other
things also but the main topic that i
want to
discuss today will be
how to generalize this completeness
result so that it can uh
sort of work even for problems that have
distributions that are
efficiently samplable
but are not efficiently computable in
the sense that we
discussed yesterday
so here by some people this would be
some of the most general kind of
distributions that one might be
interested in for combinatorial
algorithms
so that just distributions for which
there is some
efficient algorithm
that is able to
sample the distribution some efficient
randomized algorithm whose outputs are
samples from the distribution with the
correct probability
and so here efficient will be
polynomial
there are actually as kind of with
everything concerning average case
complexity
some um
tricky
fine points about the definition
particularly concerning exactly what we
mean by this algorithm running in
polynomial time
which is that if we think of the sampler
as taking a stream of bits as input
random bits
and then running in some fixed
polynomial time
and then producing a sample so then any
possible output of the algorithm is
produced with a probability
that is a
integer multiple of uh a negative power
of two
so
um
if for example in our target
distribution
something has to happen with probability
one third
it kind of just cannot be done like this
because one third k because it cannot be
expressed a ratio of an integer to a
power of two
so this kind of annoyances
could be that just by saying well we'll
uh
don't worry about
differences in distributions that are
exponentially small in statistical
distance
but actually for the
crypto people that have taught about
zero knowledge
particularly perfect zero knowledge
where it's important that you think
about distributions that are some
probable in an exact way
there are actually two
non-equivalent
notions of distribution being
exactly
sampleable
so one is to say
the distribution d is samplable
if there is some some products that runs
in
expected polynomial time
and then son
outputs samples that are exactly
as if they were sampled from
distribution d of n so that's one option
and the other is to say that there is
some s that runs in worst case
polynomial time
outputs
either
of
dn
or a
special fail symbol
outputs fail with probability i don't
know it doesn't matter less than half
and
the distribution of s of n conditioned
on
being different from fail
is precisely the distribution
d1 so if you have definition two you can
get one just by sort of running the
sampler again and again until it doesn't
fail
and if you have definition one it's not
clear that you can get definition too
and in fact there are some
distributions that
we know how to sample an expected
polynomial time
but
we don't know how to
sample in a second case we cannot just
put a timeout on
an expected point on time sampler
uh because it could just be that there
are some possible outputs that are
produced only with a small probability
all right so but um
for the
arguments that we will take pretty much
any reasonable definition of some
probability number one number two
uh
exponentially small statistical distance
uh can be ignored any of these three
options will work equally well
okay so then um
i talked a bit more about a couple of uh
questions that were asked
yesterday
so one was
i said that we have something like
plenty click
uh this distribution of input so just
kind of any kind of
um distribution of inputs with a planted
solution it could also be a stochastic
block model planted independent set
planting coloring
so is this distribution
is the cumulative probability function a
polynomial time computable
which means then we can
apply levin's result and say that it
reduces to
the bonding halting problem with respect
to the uniform distribution
and i would say probably not
and
because for uh
for many of these planted problems
uh it's also believed that not only it's
hard to find
the hidden solution
but it's also hard to
distinguish the
uh
essentially sampled from the
distribution with a planted solution
from uh
instances planted
er example without the planted solution
let's see if we take a
random graph with the planted clique of
sar is
third root of n or something much
smaller than root n
then it's not believed that there is an
efficient algorithm that will
distinguish it from just a pure g and a
half random graph
you can get a tiny distinguishing
probability
just by counting triangles or things
like that
but if you want a
probability tending to one of correctly
identifying samples from
g and a half versus plenty click that's
not believed to be
doable with an efficient algorithm
however
this property of
the cumulative probability function
being the product time computable
it also implies that
in polynomial time you can
compute the
probability of each particular instance
so now suppose i give you
like we already have a g and a half
third ocean graph we put a half a graph
with a planted clip and i ask you to
distinguish which one it is
so what you could do if uh the
distribution with the practice solution
was polynomial time computable was to
compute the probability of distance
under the distribution
and in the g and a half case almost
surely the probability will be zero
so then your distinguisher can be
compute the probability see if it's zero
because like any graph
where the maximum click is less than
what it would be in the plantar
distribution as probably zero in the
planted distribution
so you get distinguishing probability
that it's extremely close to one
uh and so let me say probably four
problems with a
platy solution where you conjecture
indistinguishability from not planting
the
solution
the
distribution is not point one-time
computable so it's not optimally
compressible using
arithmetic coding and so
as of yet
we still don't know how to prove that
say
if the money healthy problem had the
efficient algorithm under the uniform
distribution you could solve plenty
click or a
stochastic block model or
any of those problems below
the known computational thresholds
on the other hand all those
distributions are sampled because a
literally described true example say
what does
a practically distributions look like
well sample a random graph pick a subset
of vertices make them a click that's a
graph
the description that i gave is a
sampler
then
so that's one answer
then the other was um
there's
several possible definitions of uh
average case efficiency
and an appealing one
because it's preserved by the reductions
that we talked about it so
can be used in uh
instead of levels definition in the
completeness result
is to define
[Music]
average case efficiency
is saying that there is some polynomial
time algorithm
it is correct
except with negligible probability
here negligible means there is some
bound that goes to zero faster than any
polynomial so it's something like one
over and to a
drawing exponent
so one
drawback of this definition is that
it's possible for an algorithm to have
expected polynomial running time
without satisfying this definition
and
um
i mean now there is anything wrong with
that but uh
expected polynomial like at any time
there is polynomial in expectation
is something that should be
considered uh efficient or like at least
it's what would be the
first notion of uh
i mean it's really the average running
time it's polynomial so it should be
considered
effect
okay so now let's
let's see what we can do about
reducing a
a problem under the
under example distribution to bonding
halting
so essentially the current result i want
to
show today is to say that
if
there is an efficient according to any
of these definitions
algorithm for bonnet halting with
respect to the uniform distribution
then
for
every prominent p
and for every
sampleable distribution
we also have an efficient algorithm
um
and the argument that we will give will
work for uh impalazo's definition the
one where you
can get algorithms that can make
mistakes but those mistakes can be
bounded by arbitrarily small polynomials
and also this time we will have to use
randomized reductions
to sort of define randomized reductions
that preserve this kind of tractability
it's a bit messy so actually we will not
define them we just construct the
reduction and then
so study why it preserves structability
and
so the way in which we will prove this
has some similarity
with
work
done in cryptography on constructing
surrounding generators from one-way
functions
and that's not a coincidence because
this work happened around the same time
late 80s and was done by most of the
same people in palliative living luby
goldreich
and so some of the
important ideas that then later gave
right to the field of
randomness extraction
and so randomness for space boundary
computation like a lot of the
great results in complexity of the 90s
they came out from this effort of
getting several generators from one more
functions
and of reducing
kind of sample distributions to uniform
distributions
so luca just to be clear at the end of
this we will be able to say that
uh
finding a that if you could solve
bounded halting uh you could also solve
planted gleek like absolutely yes urgent
search engines okay forever including
the situation yes okay um
indeed in fact talking about search
problems we'll have to also be part of
this and will come out in the discussion
thanks
okay so just to
see
the main idea in a toy
setting
imagine that we have a
setup where for everyone
a dn is a
flat distribution
flat meaning that
it's
uniform on
its support
and it support it's a proper subset
perhaps of
all the possible strings of length
so distributions like this
could be
not computable in
11 cents because it might be hard to
tell which things are in the support and
which ones are
right for example this could be
something happens if you are looking at
the output of an injective serum
generator
okay so suppose that's uh
what is happening that we are
that when we sample
an input from this distribution
x as probability
i don't know one in two to decay
for some non k
so then in this case a
reduction that works
is to
take x
and map it into
h of x
x
where
h is a
random hash function
chosen by the reduction
net maps and 2k
actually
cc2 with a slightly different value like
with k minus three or something but
let's say
end to k
and so this is not data compression
but it's a way to
map x to something from which x is
recoverable
uniquely
but also map x to something that is
essentially uniformly distributed
yeah so when i say i output
h means output the description of the
hash function um if it's a bit wise
independent hash function just map maybe
compute it by some
matrix output the matrix
and
h of x it's just k bits
so in full the way the reduction looks
like is that
as reduction from our problem to bonnie
halting
is that x is mapped to certain machine m
h
h of x
t
so here h is randomly chosen by the
reduction
maps n bits in two k bits
m
is a nondeterministic machine
the given
h
and a
string y
guesses
an x such that h of x is equal to y
and such that x is a possible output of
the sampler
and then proceeds to solve problem p
or input x
so the point of this argument is that if
uh
the distribution
of axis in our distribution during our
the output over sampler
is
uniform on some subset
of size 2 decay
then
if our element x is hashed to k bits
there's at least a constant probability
that
this hash uniquely defined sucks
the text is the unique pre-image of
h of x
among
the two to decay
elements in the support of the
distribution
so now a non-deterministic machine can
figure out this spray image
verify that it's a possible output of
the sampler
by generating some
a random input for the sampler that
uh makes the sample output x
demonstrated in text is a possible
output of the sampler
so then now
the machine knows what x is
and can do whatever non-deterministic
principle time computation solves uh x
so then t is chosen to be large enough
that this machine can do all those
things
and so that's the reduction to bonding
halting
and
lucas so there's this failure
probability associated with the fact
that h is a random hash function it
might not like give you unique
recoverability of x but just to make
sure i understand the point like the
reason to use you need to use a random
hash function because you need
uh the input to bounded halting to be
the uniform distribution right like
otherwise you could choose a better a
function h and avoid this failure
probability but then you wouldn't have a
random input at hall tank i could choose
h to be the identity then it will be
very easily in performance
yeah
okay
yeah so define this way the success
probability
is only constant
so if i hash to
as many buckets as things that i want
the probability that the particular
element
is the unique one that goes into a
bucket will just be a constant
however if i
make this
k plus slogan
now the probability of success becomes
polynomial
when i look at this distribution now
it's not exactly uniform because here
these are k plus log n bits
but there are only k bits of entropy
in
h of x given h
just entropy of x itself
so there's this deficiency of login bits
but that's still fine uh because we can
tolerate
uh
up to
order logan
bits of deficiency in the output of
our distribution
because we just want it to be
polynomially
bonded by the uniform distribution
right so that's uh
because shows that
um
it is kind of possible to do some kind
of
mapping of an input
of a sampleable distribution to a random
input
in a way that also a random
representation
in a way that it's invertible
but it's a very
it also in a way that is different from
uh compressing the data
although you can sort of think of h of x
as being a compression of x but you also
have to present h so it's actually a
pretty big representation
but all of this works only in a very
restricted setting
so we have to assume that the
distribution is flat
and also we have to assume that we know
the entropy of the distribution and so
we know the size of the support of the
distribution
so this is more of a toy example to get
a sense of how to use action than
something is useful in itself in
particular
planted click will not quite look like
that although
i think there isn't a huge
even though the distribution is not flat
i i think it's
like most graphs have similar
probability
even after you
insert the clip
it kind of depends on how many edges
were missing
that's all the main
a g and a half is actually a flat
distribution
okay all the possible graphs have the
exact same probability one over two to
the power of n choose two
when you plan the click you
it's a bit difficult to think about
because there are
multiple ways of getting the same graph
in a sense that you forget what edges
were there among the vertices of the
click before you planted it
but
yeah i would guess it's it's pretty flat
but the
techniques that we will describe they
don't need to know the entropy and
they work for
every possible distribution
however
they work on
search problems
and so
we will have to argue that
first we need to argue that if bonnie
halting is solvable as a decision
problem
it's also solvable as a search problem
and
and that is again one of those things
that are
not very interesting my point of view of
worst case complexity decision was to
search
but
become actually kind of interesting in
the case of
average case
like so in general how do you
show that to solve a search problem it's
enough to have access to a
a decision one
for example say decision versus search
for
max click
from the worst case perspective
so say i have an algorithm
that given
g and k
decides
if there is a click of size
at least k or not
and now using such an algorithm we would
like to
compute a largest clip
and so what we can do is perhaps use
binary search to find what is the
largest scale for which you click exist
so now we know what is the largest size
of the
clicking g so
we figure out maybe the
largest click size is
some number then we can pick an
arbitrary vertex
delete it from
the graph
and then ask what
in the graph without this vertex is
there silly click of us at least 127
if
yes
now we have reduced to the goal of
finding click of
in a graph that has one less vertex than
before
if not we know that that vertex must
belong to the maximum clip
and so now we have reduced the task of
finding liquids at 126 in the remaining
graph
just among the neighbors of that vertex
so if the seal is equal 127 we find
a maximum click
in the graph
without that vertex
if not
we
find the max click just
among the neighbors of that vertex
and then we will add it after we find it
so in both cases we reduce to
finally click on a smaller graph and
this can go on at most in times
and if you think about doing something
similar in an average case setting
it's scary cannot possibly work because
if you
start from a graph that is random in
some sense
and you start
removing
vertices kind of conditioned on whether
an algorithm is telling you something or
not
you start getting graphs that
don't look like the
previous one anymore
so your
average specific algorithm
is not really guaranteed to work anymore
uh perhaps in classically you can do
uh something but
i don't think max plus action for
example
you are in good shape because you must
start getting a very asymmetric graph
actually so for max click at some point
you might get small
if you are lucky
but you see this even more for something
like
threesat
for trisat what you do is to kind of
hardwire a boolean value one of the
variables
if the formula is still satisfiable you
got it right otherwise you
know that it's the complement
and now you reduce to finding a way to
satisfy the remaining formula minus that
variable
and again a boolean formula where you
that starts random but then you
start assigning values to variables
rather it becomes something is not
random at all in fact it's not even a
threesome formula anymore because you
start shrinking clauses
okay so uh
how do you
how can you do a
decision versus search without
messing up these distributions
too much
so we're going to describe how to
uh
so the reduction will go from
[Music]
a bonded whole thing in the uniform
distribution
as a search problem
to
the decision version
right so we start off from some machine
and some x
and some bound t
it's a search problem so it means that
we don't just want to know if i'm accept
sex we want to find some weakness that
i'm accepts
and
now suppose that we
suppose that we
knew that there is a
a
either a unique witness or no witness
so then we can
kind of construct a
a series of instances and then feed all
of them to the
an algorithm for the decision version a
suppose witness is a plant
each of
these decision problems
is asking
[Music]
so we create this l plus one decision
problems so first of all we ask you know
is there a witness at all
that's the decision version of uh
max if it says no then
there is
no weakness we have nothing we just
answered no
um otherwise
or in any case
we solve these other l
decision problems
where each of them is asking
is there a witness for x
where
the first bit is one is the witness for
x in which the second bit is one is
there a witness for x in which the
eighth bit is one and so on
now imagine that all these
questions are answered
correctly so if there is no weakness
there is no weakness
if there is a witness
uh say that we are assuming that in that
case it has to be unique
well then the answers to those l
questions will tell us this unique
witness which bit is zero and put speed
is one so we can reconstruct it
now also if x is random
um
each of those machines m one and two
mi and so on
they're just the
such original machine
plus a number between one and l
so here
this first part takes at least
log l bits
this part is random
and
this part is just
kind of determined from where the
canon
we said the way the instance is
constructed is that first we choose some
point after which it's all t it's all
once they describe t before that it's
all random
so where this line goes
only changes probabilities by
one over the length of the whole string
this part is random this part it's
the local bits l is polynomial in n so
these are order of log n bits
so the whole thing is random perhaps
with a logan entropy deficiency so again
it's dominated polynomially by the
uniform distribution
so if we have an algorithm that is good
in
polyacros sense
for the decision problem it means that
for almost all the axes
we can get all these answers uh
correctly
and so for almost all the axis we can
either determine that there is no
witness or find the witness when it
exists
so with problems for a
unique witness
the
reduction to search
[Music]
position to search reduction it's very
simple
uh what do we do when
the witness is not unique
uh
we make it unique with valiant what's
day
okay
so the
the general way this
reduction will
look like
is that
starting from
m x
and t
will actually kind of construct a bunch
of instances so the reduction will
pick
a
random hash function h
and then we'll kind of
construct a bunch of machines
they say they are indexed by
parameter k and the parameter i there is
accidentally some t because this t is
not the same
and both this parameter k
goes from 0 to l i goes from 1 to one
so what does mki
do
give an x
oh another is also
h in each of these instances
so given x and h
it checks if
there is a witness
such that the
ice bit
is one
and maybe this weakness we call it w
and
h of w
starts with k zeros
right so the
reduction creates
roughly else square
instances of
bonded halting
decision bonding halting
and each of the systems is asking
whether
one of the pos so it's asking for a
weakness of x
it was this witness is to uh
satisfy certain harsh conditions and
also to have a certain bit equal to
1.
so this is a logic for that
and also what do we do
in that so we
assuming we have an algorithm for the
decision version of boundary halting
we will
run it on
all these instances
then how do we collect the result
for
each case we said well
let's imagine that uh
there was actually witness
for
a unique witness
uh having
its uh hash value
start with k zeros
well then the answers to all those
questions are telling us what are the
bits of this witness
let's deconstruct it
let's check if it's actually a weakness
if it is we are good
otherwise we'll try a different value of
k
if
none of the values of k work out
we say well then maybe there is no
witness
so that's the
reduction
before i try to analyze it just want to
check if
description of the reduction is making
sense
questions in the local audience
what's that some are the questions in
the local audience or the zoom audience
yeah guy
sorry so just to clarify so it's uh
you're claiming that there's at least
um one k that has uh uh for which
there's a unique uh witness with this
modified problem yeah so the idea of the
reaction is to argue that
no matter how many weaknesses there are
there will be two to the k for some k
then for
that k
exactly one of them
will have the first k bits of the hash
function uh being uh zero
or at least that will happen at least
with constant probability
okay perfect yeah yeah
yeah
um
so in fact basically that's the
analysis it says
you know if there is no weakness there
is no witness no matter what we do we
will not find a witness and that's
actually the correct answer
if there is a witness well there is at
least one how many are there there will
be some number of them
now if k
is log of however many weaknesses there
are
then we would expect that with constant
probability
exactly one of them
will
have a hash value with
precisely
k-0s at the beginning
because sort of
there are kind of two decay events each
one happens with one input to decay
the probability that precisely one of
them happens
is a is a constant
so with constant probability for that k
this process
will isolate one witness
and
we will reconstruct it
if this could also work for other values
of k that we reconstructed witness
but the point is that
for at least one value of k we will be
able to reconstruct a witness
provided that all those answers are
all those questions are answered
correctly
in fact we cannot guarantee that all
these questions will be answered
correctly
but
the questions with the right value of k
like the questions where k is log of the
number of weaknesses
um
sorry forget um
we can sort of hope that in fact all the
questions will be answered correctly
because when we look at
what all these instances look like
so h is random
x is random
t doesn't really matter
and
this it's
a constant plus
two log
bits so the only entropy deficiency is
coming from the description of the
machine that's
order of logan so it affects the
probability only as a inverse polynomial
okay
now
now
it's it's not great that it only
works with constant probability
uh
because we would like more like inverse
polynomial probability or something like
that
but
this can be done several times in
parallel like instead of doing it with
just one hash function we can do it with
n
hash
functions so then for every hash
function for every k for every i we have
one of these instances it's still
polynomial
now
for one
choice of the hash function the
probability of
isolating a weakness for the right value
of k is a constant
if we try n times the probability that
we never isolate it is only
exponentially small
so here actually the reduction by itself
succeeds except with exponentially small
probability
there is still an inverse polynomial
probability that
we get some wrong answers from our
algorithm is allowed to be wrong
sometimes
but the
randomness of the reduction
does what it's supposed to do except
with exponentially small probabilities
okay so that's how you
reduce
search to decision
you
isolate the
a unique witness
and you
to ask for its bit one at a time
to isolate the witness you have to know
how many there are you don't know but
you can try all possibilities and that's
the reduction
exactly i mean necessarily but this
would be
a good place to take a break
so
how about we sounds that sounds
reasonable
uh so that means we start again at
40 past the hour
yeah i think that sounds right guy do
you agree okay yeah we'll start at 40
past the hour see you all
thanks luka
[Applause]